my field is high energy theoretical
physics and my field of study is
biochemistry neuronal proliferation is
regulated first we do formative tests
[Music]
the language of science can be a bit
difficult to understand but the reason
science is hard to listen to is because
it's hard to communicate just ask
Natalie a climate scientist who teaches
at George Mason University
Laughlin with my class you have the
students attention for only a few
minutes so it becomes very important for
me to think how could I become a more
effective communicator
that's where actor Alan Alda comes in he
runs an organization that helps
scientists like Natalie clearly
communicate their field of study and
they do it using improv comedy
I wondered if I've worked with
scientists on learning to do some of the
basic exercises of improv I could get
this connection established between
scientists and their audience so I
thought let me try it
[Music]
we established a program to start with
basic improv exercises so that
scientists can communicate better I'm
Melanie and this is Sarah we trained a
really wide range of people people from
NASA people from the parks department
physicians and medical researchers we do
a lot of physical ization of emotion and
thoughts in these exercises the main
thing for me is that they help you
connect to another person
Nataly took the workshop to help teach
her class since then she's been able to
connect with her students in a new way
the number one thing that I've started
doing differently since the workshop is
thinking would I have known this word
when I was a first-year University
student would I have been as comfortable
with this concept and as a result that
makes me empathize more and clearly
articulate the concepts and the step by
step process so what would happen to
this molecule at zero Kelvin so when I
look out of my class and ice emphasize
that message that everything they're
learning along the way is so that they
can have an understanding of how climate
change actually works and they can
communicate that since they began the
Center has had over 14,000 people go
through the workshops I think good
communication is very important not just
about science and not just about
medicine but good communication makes
the wheels turn we needed in every
activity of our lives so your message is
built on the idea of connection and
relating which i think is one of the
most important things we can do for one
another
you